who are your favorite Asian actors
Okay so
I love Jackie Chan
and I love what he's done and I love how
he brought comedy
or I would say comedic gestures with
almost all of his films
um
and on the opposite end I would say Jet
Li because in my time in the 90s growing
up and stuff you had Jackie Chan and you
had Jet Lee Jackie Chan was the colorful
fun one Jet Li was the serious one and I
know there are martial arts a lot of
times incorporated into their films but
those two were the ones that I remember
growing up watching all the time
so if we gave you let's say fifty
dollars right now
can you name 50 Asian American actors
absolutely not from the 1960s 70s 80s
and 90s 50 from all those decades
combined uh no I can't what motivates
you to make movies more than anything
else
so it's a few things I really want to
influence a generation
of American Asians I want to
even if it's to crack that barrier
I want to move that barrier as much as I
can and what I mean by that is like
I want to see Asian Americans in
American Cinema playing every role
I don't want to see us stuck to be in
the sidekick
the the nerdy friend
the Kung Fu karate guy
I want us to play every role like
in Top Gun
what if the Top Gun pilot the lead guy
was an Asian guy
it's about a pilot right or you know
um
even something like Batman Batman you
could get away with an Asian American
just because it's the dark hair the
build you can kind of get away with that
um
I really want to help even Fast and
Furious one of my favorite movies of all
time
you know if Vin Diesel's character or
Paul Walker's character was an
Asian-American guy
be fantastic because now you're just
seeing that right
it changes the landscape of what someone
sees as possible when they're able to
see it happen consistently not the
one-offs because you're always going to
have the one-offs
but when you're able to see big
blockbusters
with an Asian American in the leading
role the main guy or main female
I think it changes the Dynamics for a
whole generation because now
somebody else can see that and say well
I can do that too so now you have a
plethora of films you have a bunch of
different creators and writers and the
filmmakers directors coming out with
these projects because they've seen it
it's like
um I don't remember the exact name but
there was a long time where the four
minute mile
uh that it took for someone to run a
four minute mile and then once he did it
I think it was like weeks or months or
19 days I forget the exact number for
someone else to break that four minute
mile
but he had to have broken it first
in order for someone else to see that
it's possible and then everyone else
broke the four minute mile
so it's the same thing with film
you have to see
Someone Like You break that mold
for you to say
okay I can do that too
yeah absolutely I can do that too
so you know it's similar to
Keanu Reeves right Keanu Reeves is a
great example of someone that broke that
mold
but how many Keanu Reeves are there
not that many so I'm hoping to to help
break that door whether it's the front
door side door we built a new house in
that neighborhood
and and present the to the world that
hey we're more than just the punch line
Dean Kane yes and Dean Cannon Dean Kane
played Superman sure
great example
so I I think that if we're able to do
more of that
we're able to to impact Cinema in a
large way and if you think about it from
a business standpoint
there's so many Asians in the world
why wouldn't you want to tap into that
market
full blast
when you were going on auditions in La
um what did casting directors tell you
was your look and did you ever turn down
roles because you thought I don't want
to play a stereotype so I turned down a
lot of roles in Atlanta
or a lot of I'm not gonna say roles
because they weren't presented but
auditions where I didn't even audition
for them and it could have probably hurt
me where the castner at some point was
like all right we don't even want to see
him because he turns everything down but
in LA
I was so hungry for any role
that I would have taken any role
but it was always the same rules where
the same actors were always in the room
in hindsight
it was great because you know you're
getting an opportunity because again no
one's going to create that role for you
unless you created yourself because
you're not proven right I'm not proven
um
unless something does well that I'm in
in this particular role because now
there's data associated with that where
it's like okay well people like seeing
this guy play this role
there's no data behind it then there's
no gauge and if there's no gauge there's
no money that you can associate it with
it because every time you spend a dollar
they want to get two or three back
so
the machine itself did
what worked for for hundreds of years
but in order to innovate we have to
innovate we have to create and become
the creators
so you would take any role in La what
did the casting directors tell you was
your look do you know
so here's where I had a double-edged
sword
when they looked at my picture they're
like okay great bring them in
when I opened my mouth
they were like he's not the guy
so it worked in commercials and print
but I was never Asian enough
so because I was never Asian enough
when I opened my mouth
they said I sound too Urban
those are the exact words you sound too
Urban You're not Asian enough
it's
it's interesting
because
I know when they say you're not Asian
enough I know what that means
I know what they're looking for
and they're right I'm not that and
in hindsight
I just want to
show that everyone is everyone
sure we all have common pains we all
have common Joys you know emotions are
Universal
so words can be interpreted differently
depending on the language and where
you're from
but a happy emotion regardless of where
you're from is the same
a sad emotion is the same
so the one thing that's beautiful about
films is you're able to evoke those
emotions and a lot of times those
emotions span Beyond where you're from
that when you came to Atlanta and you
were more established with your day job
and and well rooted you turned down
rules was it the same thing you felt
like okay now I don't want to contribute
to the stereotype being out there
absolutely 100 so when I I want to say
gain the power of creating films so when
I did my first film it was my film
school right I learned everything from
YouTube film courage I decided that okay
I'm gonna shoot this film right I was
working I.T I started writing the film
during my break so when I wasn't doing
anything started shooting it on the
weekends casting it all that stuff
is it a great film absolutely not you're
either gonna love it or hate it but it
taught me so much where the what you see
on screen from first film the second
film
has such a drastic jump up in quality
and Style and what I'm trying to
accomplish that that first film needed
to happen in order for me to LeapFrog
because that did two things it let me
know what I needed to get better at and
then it let me know that I can do it
again because you did it
so that's why it's so important for
filmmakers to get that first one don't
wait for the right opportunity don't
wait for the right time don't wait for
the right circumstances we all want to
shoot 100 000 cameras and lenses and and
have you know 10 hours to shoot one
scene but when you're an indie filmmaker
you're gonna shoot 10 scenes in three
hours
you're not going to get that many takes
because you only have this location for
four
and you have to set up pack up shoot get
out clean it up make sure you leave it
better than where you when you got in
so
that stability
was was crucial
and allowing me to create